this week on the climate Show with Tom
Heap I'm talking rubbish and about how
more of this stuff could be getting into
our rivers and seas as a result of
climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show on
the program this week yep it's the
return of rubbish Heap and we're going
to be revealing the extraordinary
landfills next to the sea that are
eroding and dumping this stuff in our
Waters
in Bosnia we hear how a warmer than
usual winter with heavy rain has led to
disaster with River flooding sweeping up
tons of waste from poorly regulated
landfills and dumps
and what does minus 50 degrees feel like
the cold just catches in your throat as
soon as you're out our Asia
correspondent Helen Ann Smith joins me
from China's most Northerly city after
it experiences its coldest day ever
sitting on top of an old landfill site
on the Thames Estuary and the reason you
can see What Lies Beneath here is that
every day the tide and the current wash
this stuff away there are over a
thousand Coastal landfill sites around
the country and many of them are being
eroded so how bad is this for marine
life and what can be done to stop it
for as long as Humanity has lived by the
water we've dropped stuff in it
the history of our settlement by the
Thames and other British tidal Rivers is
written on the riverbed and mudlock
moniker knows how to read it do you have
any luck today
um found a few bits my favorite piece is
this which is the Dockers hook so I I
absolutely love that it's just so much
an integral part of London history
you need a license to scour the tideline
here as the fines can be historic and
precious so what we've got here all
sorts of lovely things we've got a
Georgian Buckle so that came off the
silk shoe because I know I found the
sole but no leather and just a buckle on
the top so by the absence of material we
know the silk would have decayed but the
shoe wouldn't I love saving the history
of London this is all like I'm a born
and bred Londoner so this is my
ancestors what do you think about the
fact that you're finding you know now
plastic bits in here
um I'm gutted for the future for what
what we leave behind I think we've got
to go
further Downstream a few miles east of
the M25 and what we've discarded is less
like an occasional artifact and more of
a crust
it is one of the weirdest coasts I've
ever walked on because when you look in
the distance you think oh this is a
fairly normal Coast but then as your
eyes come down it's just hideous isn't
it yeah and it's really kind of the
layers of plastic and old historical
waste that is really the concern but how
do you feel when you see places like
this well it's it's a bit devastating
really and much of it hasn't traveled
far this was a rubbish dump and a
landfill site from the Victorian era
right up until 1991.
older in fact there are thousands of
disused landfill sites across the UK
lots of them dotted along our coasts
that were opened before environmental
regulations came into Force many of them
are now at risk of coastal erosion
it's really hard to believe this until
you've actually been here it's the way
you've got this extraordinary variety of
old stuff of ours this is a bit of tire
oh that's elastic
rotting plastic and the way it's mixed
in with the natural world with all the
roots dangling here and the Earth are
almost like geological seams of our
waste sins of the Past coming through
and it's not just here there are places
similar to this around much of the
country
what was buried is returning to haunt us
this is a thing that we're worried about
in in the tidal Thames is that it's it
can be old plastic that is they've been
here for a very long time almost been
preserved but now as it starts to come
out it starts to be exposed to the the
elements and the river itself is really
when it starts to break down and it then
it can really make its way into really
really small pieces into they call them
microplastics they're worrying thing
here it's not just the plastics it's
also the Hazardous chemicals
um that can be a really serious issue
for wildlife that like if we let this
out into the river it could really
devastate Wildlife here
in a survey out this month 26 councils
admitted they have waste sites already
spilling onto beaches and into the sea
just three said they had sufficient
funds to protect Coastal dumps in an era
of climate change zombie garbage is
awakened it's a whole complex of things
natural processes which are changed by
human intervention and then of course we
have got sea level rise which can be a
problem because you end up with for
example sort of increased storminess or
the waves are starting to attack things
at a higher level what if anything can
we do about these eroding Coastal
landfill sites the bottom line is that
with some of them if we want to avoid
this stuff just being tipped
uncontrollably into the sea you know
relocation of the material has got to be
fairly high on the list of options but
there is little evidence of councils
governments or the waste companies who
ran the dumps finding the millions
possibly billions required to staunch
these Wellsprings of trash there's
things that we thought were away we we
disposed of them we gave them to the
local authorities we thought they were
gone they were being properly managed
and actually that really wasn't the case
and now it's it's something that we all
have to deal with
in Bosnia this winter they've had a
similar problem to this unseasonably
heavy rain has caused rivers to flood
and tear apart many of their landfill
sites environmentally so worried about
the damage and what to do to clean it up
plastic bags bottles and even an old
fridge are choking the Drina River
days of torrential rain and flooding
have left this Bosnia Herzegovina Beauty
Spot crammed with an estimated 10 000
cubic meters of rubbish
waste from poorly regulated Riverside
landfills has accumulated behind a
barrier in the river and it isn't the
first time it's happened
through no fault of our own the visit
Grand municipality has turned into a
regional waste site the solution exists
we must urgently register all illegal
garbage dump sites on the banks of our
Rivers this is not just a huge
environmental and health hazard but it's
also a big embarrassment for all of us
like much of Europe the Balkans have
experienced unseasonably warm weather
and downpours causing streams and rivers
to overflow
people need to wake up this is a serious
problem
the cleanup of these once pristine
Waters has begun but it's thought it
could take up to six months
and now for a waste issue a little
closer to home have you ever noticed
those multi-colored bits of plastic
Vapes that often gather on the curbside
well Laurie Young from Dundee has she
goes by the name of the Vape Crusader or
less waste Laura
my name is Laura young and I'm
campaigning to get single-use disposable
Vapes banned in the UK this industry
started with reusable models which could
be refilled with Solutions and recharged
when people needed to top them up now
single-use disposable models have surged
onto the market with over 1.3 million
being sold every single week these
devices contain many different materials
including a lithium ion battery this
means that over 1.3 million of these
devices including the battery are being
thrown away because they are branded as
disposable every single week with the
majority of them going into landfill and
general waste I often go on walks to see
how many I can find and commonly I find
about one every single minute where I
live in Dundee I went on an hour's walk
and found 55 in that time this is the
latest collection that I have and I need
to go and recycle it one of the problems
with recycling these is that it is not a
available curbside I have to take it to
my local recycling center which is over
three miles away and you need to
actually book an appointment a slot and
you need to go in a car
that is me just leaving the recycling
center after disposing of the Vapes one
interesting point is that I double
checked with the staff at the center
about where I should be putting these
they had never actually been asked where
these should go before no one had
brought them in and asked them if they
are to be recycled or if they're going
to General waste they are now actually
going to go and ask their company
exactly how these are supposed to be
disposed of just to double check and
make sure but it's interesting to know
that our waste industry is not 100 sure
of where these items are supposed to be
disposed of how these are supposed to be
recycled and when we have 1.3 million
being used every single week in the UK
you can see that this could become a big
problem very quickly
it's great to see the progress that the
Scottish government is making people ask
stakeholders with relevant expertise to
examine the evidence and assess what
action the Scottish government and other
partners should take and that will
include consideration of a potential
banner I hope that they see that banning
is the clear way to move forward
alongside greater regulation and I hope
this influences the UK government to do
more
and Laura sent us a question which we
put to environment secretary Therese
coffee she asked the Scottish government
is urgently considering a ban on
disposable single-use of Vapes would you
support a ban on these products too
I wasn't aware the Scottish government
were considering that I know that
that health professionals consider
moving to vaping is a good way to try
and reduce smoking but any particular
aspects of banning is not under
consideration
after the break we'll be off to Northern
China which is experiencing record cold
temperatures
and also catching up with a bird watcher
a young Enthusiast who believes that
climate change and the warmer winter
weather is confusing some of our native
birds
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show as you
can see I'm away from the mud Banks and
in the studio and it's cozy in here
unlike this place MOA in China it's
known as China's North Pole but this
week temperatures plunged to record lows
even here a bone chilling minus 53
degrees Centigrade the country's coldest
day ever just as China rang in the Lunar
New Year climate change tends to
exaggerate extremes at both ends of the
scale and this comes just months after
China's longest heat wave in decades
temperatures were as high as 45 degrees
in Chongqing a new record outside the
desert region of xinjiang I caught up
with Skies Asia correspondent Helen Ann
Smith from moha where she's been
reporting this week
hello Dan it's great to see you I can
see your breath and the people behind
you
um I thought it was cold here next to
the Thames what's it like for you
well it is just absolutely freezing
there's no more basic way to put it than
that it's one of those things when you
talk about these sort of minus 40s minus
50s temperatures do you think you might
be able to picture what that might feel
like and then you get here and then it
just hits you like a ton of bricks it's
the sort of cold that kind of catches in
your lungs it makes you want to cough it
literally takes your breath away and
then any bit of moisture on your body
has that sort of sensation of kind of
freezing up instantly so your eyelashes
your eyelids your nostrils and as a team
we have to be really careful not
spending a long amount of period our
time a lot of period out outside and
keeping our skin uh concealed but this
place I mean it's used to cold here this
is known as China's North Pole this
Village it is literally the furthest
North Town and Village in the whole
country and just over the river just
over there over the Frozen river is the
border with Russia so this is typically
a cold place but this week it has been
historically cold minus 53 degrees years
earlier in the week and that is a new
record in the entire entire modern
history of China according to the
meteorological office here
uh how unusual is it and are people
linking it to climate change
well look this is a cold place typically
this time of year it would definitely be
in the sort of you know minus 20 region
pretty regularly here so it's not as if
they're not used to the cult here but
just the scale of the cold that minus 53
that was recorded that is as I said a a
new historic Milestone group and
actually their previous record all the
way back in 1969 um but I spoke to one
gentleman a man called Mr Shear who runs
a very small kind of convenience store
shop and he's been talking to me about
those extremities of weather that he's
noticed and in their whole life he spent
here he said uh in recent years he's
noticed those extremes foreign
so look as you know Tom it's not as if
we can say that any individual event is
absolutely because of climate change
without further research but what we do
know about China in particular is that
this country just this year has seen
these absolute extremes of weather the
summer just gone by the country recorded
historic heat waves historic droughts we
saw these incredible pictures of great
sways of the Yangtze River completely
dried up and the authorities here spoke
about just how extreme that Heatwave was
and then we compare it now to these
historic colds so climate change of
course as we know does play a role in
exacerbating these extreme climate
events there's scientific work for
example linking
um warming sea Waters to excessive cold
events so we know some of these changes
are happening and the people here say
they are worried about it but of course
we have to be careful about that
individual links but as I say Tom it is
quite extraordinary to experience colds
of just this degree
now for a little on what's been making
news in climate this week and for that
I've been catching up Riverside again
with our climate reporter Victoria
Seabrook
Victoria last time we met was at the big
climate Summit in Egypt here we are on
the banks of the Thames but talking
again about these cop Summits because a
lot of arguments about the president of
the new cop
um this guy who runs the Abu Dhabi
National oil company who's going to be
chairing the meeting seems bizarre yes
there's been a lot of hoo-ha about it
this week again so he is a government
Minister but he also heads up this huge
Oil Company Sultan Al de bear and
campaigners have condemned the
appointment they've said that this big
International climate diplomacy process
that agrees the collective Global next
steps on climate change is cannot be
legitimate if you've got the head of an
oil company presiding over it that's
what they say there is another view of
him but just before we get there what
does a president of a cop song actually
do what's his influence his influence is
huge so the role of the host nation is
to drive the talks in a particular
direction to seek consensus to hold
Lagarde governments to account and at
the at the very Forefront of that
process is the single appointed cop
president in effect he's setting the
agenda so we're going to decide what's
on it what's of it yes and there's a lot
of concern if he's the head of an oil
company does he and does the UAE have a
vested interest in maintaining the
status quo they've also got very good
relationship with other oil producing
Nations like Saudi Arabia which is not
renowned for its ambition at these kind
of summits but you've heard from some
people who actually are welcoming the
appointment some of them with pretty
strong green credentials as well yeah so
this week I was at an event at the
Canadian embassy we heard from Lord Zach
Goldsmith up here but also a government
Minister here in the UK and also
Canada's climate Ambassador and they
were both saying uh we were they're
going to do a superb job the UAE we've
been there recently they're very
ambitious on Solutions things like that
John Kerry the U.S climate Envoy has
also welcomed the appointment but that's
not totally surprising because after all
these are negotiations this is a huge
exercise in diplomacy so they always
speak highly of each other in public
even if they may have reservations they
may be just making the best of a bad job
we wait and see I'm a bit closer to home
we've had a big announcement on farming
this week and farming subsidy yeah the
government has finally given all the
detail about it as how it is going to
pay farmers and in the form of subsidies
and other rural payments and they are
now going to incentivize them to protect
nature and meet climate targets
alongside also producing food this is
the thing ever since we left the EU and
they had their cap payments which
broadly encourage production we've now
moved away to encourage more wildlife
and carbon storage is that in there too
yes that's right so now farmers will be
incentivized or they'll be able to claim
claim payments for things like planting
wildflowers boosting hedgerows managing
Woodland in the more radical end of the
spectrum actually transforming their
land away from farming into things like
Woodland although that doesn't always go
down well that idea with Farmers so it's
a it's a very positive step there's a
long way to go yeah and and it's very
controversial especially when it comes
to what we do with our land that is
something we will be looking at probably
next week Victoria thank you very much
now time to get one of your questions
answered here's Mike via the website
heat pumps are more popular in colder
countries than in the UK yet I still
hear people say they will wait for
hydrogen boilers instead should I hold
out for hydrogen he asks well for an
answer we turn to Jan rosnell director
of European programs at the regulatory
assistance project a clean energy Think
Tank
thanks for the question Mike you can
install a heat pump today which we
already reduce the carbon emissions from
your heating immediately heat pumps out
tried and tested technology they're
widely used in Scandinavia because
they're so efficient and it is actually
highly uncertain whether hydrogen will
ever be available for Home Heating and
the government in Industry do not expect
there to be much hydrogen for at least
another 15 years so waiting for hydrogen
to come and save us is a risky strategy
it's a bit like waiting for
teleportation whereas you can take the
train today and all independent analysis
shows that hydrogen would more expensive
and much less efficient than heat pumps
so if you want to reduce the emissions
today the best thing you can do is to
install a heat pump
and if you have a burning question about
the climate or environment scan the QR
code on the screen right now and we'll
do our best to answer it on the program
now for over four decades the rspb big
Garden Bird Watch has given a snapshot
of the nation's bird populations mapping
steep declines in some favorites like
the song thrush it's happening over this
weekend and we've been with Maya Rose
Craig a young bird watching Enthusiast
who reveals how things are changing
my name is Maya Rose Craig I'm 20 years
old and I am a very passionate bird but
as well as an environmental campaigner
that is a mallard over there um just
sort of hanging out on the eye
[Music]
a very obsessive bird watchers that's
how I got into Birds watching my parents
my older sister used to take me out I
have definitely noticed the impact of
the changing climate on our bird life
the time of year when birds are
migrating has started shifting they're
getting a bit more confused because the
temperature and the weather just feels a
bit off to them
this is causing problems because Birds
very often wait until there's a real
surge in terms of food resources and
that's when they decide to make their
nests and to breed and then a second
winter essentially comes in and it is
really badly affecting bird populations
personally I've always loved doing the
rspb's big Garden Bird Watch I think
it's such a nice easy way to engage with
nature in the outdoors and I think it
really makes you slow down and realize
what you have locally even if you live
in more urban areas where you maybe feel
like you don't have much Wildlife but
there's also such an important piece of
Citizen science of people coming
together and figuring out what exactly
is going on with our bird population in
the winter especially when it's getting
really really cold it's really important
that we're helping our bird populations
and one of the main ways you can do that
is just by putting food out but also
Birds having access to water is really
important sort of maybe putting out a
bowl of water that you make sure doesn't
get iced over makes a big difference for
your local bird population there are so
many Fantastic Urban green spaces that
you can go and visit and one of the
reasons that I personally love birds so
much is because they are literally
everywhere whether that is the middle of
the city or the middle of the
countryside
[Music]
now before we go just a reminder that
you can catch the daily climate show on
weekdays at 3 30 p.m here on Sky News
and you can get all the latest climate
and environmental news on the Sky News
app and website or by scanning the QR
code on your screen right now
and that's it from me this week we'll be
back at the same time next week to talk
about all things land and how the way we
use it is changing or maybe should
change
[Music]